former Vice President Joe Biden is
making noise he's doing very well yeah
Joe Biden doing very well Joe Biden
raised over two million dollars in just
two days while he was in Florida that's
amazing yeah amazing
in Florida raised two million dollars
probably due to his speech entitled hey
I'm your age my old person his hands
fall off when he claps sure sure Bernie
Sanders said he's going to crash
Walmart's annual shareholders meeting in
protest Bernie's not gonna crash it yeah
okay this could be risky because the
last time Bernie got close to a Walmart
they made him a greeter
income despairity settle down where the
garden hoses fun that's my Bernie that's
all it is is him it's not fair it's not
accurate your Bernie seems to be
attacking being attacked by bird yeah
everybody or bees big story today
president Trump was supposed to meet
with Democrats today to discuss
infrastructure but he stormed out of the
meeting after three minutes yeah
then Melania Trump said hey for him
three minutes he's a long time
that's my Trump is I just Channel
Mussolini just sort of
[Laughter]